for you are you doing this new album
straight Indie yeah bankroll and
everything yeah everything what
producers are you working with
I mean I'm working with quite a few
producers you know what I'm saying some
guys from the East I got a
Trey and some of them guys that did like
you know some of my [__] on my on my
older projects you know what I'm saying
um mustard I did you know you reckon
with mustard yeah
is that gonna be a single
uh
probably like you get a mustard beet I
mean I mean yeah you know I'm still
putting it together you know what I'm
saying I'm still putting the whole album
together I like to finish like
everything you know and then and then I
always been the kind of guy that
finished everything and and then pick my
singles except for like king of Chevys I
was just like you know it was on the
podcast first and everything you know it
was just one of them records we was just
having fun you know but
the red printer is is a good solid
project when you guys drop
well bow down was 96 right am I tripping
or is that 96. you could tell me more
than what about it was about 96 or 97
probably like 96 or 96 probably a 97
probably book yeah do you feel like when
you look back at those days that like um
the media like the source The Vibes of
the worlds were kind of like creating
this East Coast West Coast narrative
that necessarily was not as big as it
really was
um
I think we I mean to a certain to a
certain extent but but at the same time
it was going on it was actually going it
was going on you know what I'm saying
but yeah like of course
you know beefs and [__] like that you
know it makes for better press you know
don't ain't nobody gonna say that you
know everything is cool that ain't that
ain't a good story right it's only a
story of everybody like Feud and [__]
you know what I'm saying but yeah it
definitely was a situation going on and
yeah all media Outlets do that to a
certain extent yeah but it but there it
you know we did feel some kind of way at
the time yeah it felt like it was like
you know there was like certain artists
kind of taking like Subs at each other
back then and then there'd be like but
then you'd see like you know Method Man
pop up with Tupac you know what I'm
saying or you I mean even a little after
that you were obviously real tight with
Fat Joe Fat Joe yeah yeah because
players recognize players Man game
recognized game yeah you feel me like
man it's players everywhere you know and
like I said I ain't I I wouldn't be the
kind of guy to have this a problem
with an entire I got a problem with who
got a problem with me straight up just
like you [__] with who [__] with you
period you know what I'm saying and and
and you know that's it I got some real
solid dudes that that I've met over the
years from New York and from the East
Coast you know some solid guys yeah